That's how would be here for who you
pretend that you know,
but you don't know believe you really
have to disagree with you.
I spend a lot of time with the stock.
Open minded.
You are not
this your Carlson,
what happened to you man used to be
affable,
used to be friendly.
You used to wear a nice time.
Now you wear bibs and I don't know.
So I don't know what happened to you
man,
but I want you to consider that uh,
from the scientific perspective,
pick the number you like 97% of the
world's scientists,
very close to 100% of the world.
Scientists are very concerned about
climate change.
And so why aren't some people concerned
about it when media outlets were allowed
to be consolidated and the 1980s then it
developed these two factions like that.
I don't remember it having a,
and by that I think two factions or a
normal course of events where you,
you have males and females,
your boys and girls,
whether it's fruit flies or dandelions
or you and me and in the World Cup
soccer,
you end up with two teams.
The World Series Baseball,
It's really hard to have three teams.
And so I think and we to two political
parties normally.
So somebody who understands this better
than I do,
who may observe that the media have
divided into two camps.
But from our point of view in the
science and engineering side,
you got to respect the facts at some
level.
You got to respect their scientifically
provable.
And then speaking of authorities and
mistrust of authorities,
the crowd on a,
at the inauguration,
I was objective,
we smaller crowd than the crowd the next
day at the women's March.
So when you,
if someone asserts that the crowd is
bigger when it was curly,
smaller than everything else here she
says subject to question and this has
led to a lot of trouble.
So,
uh,
I think though that built into the u s
government,
which includes the first amendment of
the bill of rights,
the freedom of the press built in is
change.
So I'm very hopeful and optimistic that
things will change.
That my understanding is subscriptions
to so called mainstream media,
Washington Post New York Times.
And so on and have gone up in response
to these,
to this approach to objective truths.
So that will probably be to the good,
uh,
but how are fast,
what happened and what will go wrong.
In the meantime it says these are big
questions and then as far as my thing
with Mr. Carlson,
I don't know,
he used to not interview that way.
He used to not just talk about it
because it's unknowable.
Okay.
It takes you quite a bit less than six
seconds.
I go back again in a second.
Mr. Carlson,
do you have me on again?
I will come right back on.
Bring it on man.
And you know what else Mr. Carlson,
I'll bet you $10,000 that 2010 2020 will
be the hottest decade on record.
I offered a bed of $10,000 to Joe
Bastardi who is a Fox News contributor
and Marc Morano who I'm not sure as a
contributor,
but used to appear on your station
routinely.
You're a network routinely.
I bet them each 10,000 bucks,
2010 2020 will be the hottest decade on
record.
I bet them each another 10th.
Oh,
did I say 20 10,000 bucks on the decade?
10,000 Bucks on the year 2016 2016 would
have been among the top 10 hottest years
on record.
Uh,
wait,
there's more.
2016 was the hottest year on record.
And your guys,
the people that Fox News here to forest
supports in this would not take either
bet.
$40,000 wouldn't take the bet.
It could have been theirs.
I'm good for it.